let's think about the market for plastic
bags
plastic
bags and i'm picking this market in
particular because there might be some
costs associated with plastic bags that
aren't captured when you're only looking
at it from the point of view of the
suppliers or the consumers so right over
here you have a demand curve and that's
really the demand coming from the
supermarkets so this is the demand curve
you could also view it as marginal
benefit so that very first bag that gets
produced a supermarket gets a lot of
marginal benefit they'd really want to
get that bag because then they could
give it to their the people who shop at
the supermarket and they can carry their
bags home but then each incremental bag
after that the marginal benefit gets
lower and lower and lower and this green
curve over here we've seen this multiple
times that is our supply curve which we
can also think of it as our marginal
cost curve to produce that very first
bag the opportunity cost for that very
first bag is about looks like about a
penny per bag and then it gets higher
and higher and higher as we produce more
and more bags and we have an equilibrium
price in an equilibrium quantity our
equilibrium quantity looks like it's
about three and a half million bags we
have an equilibrium price of about two
cents per bag and if we just if if this
were all of the costs and all of the
benefits then this area right over here
would show the total the aggregate total
benefit that the ecosystem here that the
suppliers and the could and the and the
and the consumers or the or the the
supermarkets or the consumers in this
case are getting from this transaction
marginal benefit higher than marginal
cost marginal benefit higher than
marginal cost this whole area is our
total surplus and we've seen that
multiple times but now let's think about
that added cost that plastic bags have
that are not factored in to the costs
and the prices or the costs and the
benefits right over here plastic bags
have a negative externality
negative
negative externality
there is a cost associated so this it's
negative because there's a cost
associated with plastic bags that is not
being born by either in this situation
that is not being factored into the
marginal cost curve you can also have
positive externalities which are a
benefit maybe you're talking about the
market for trees and society benefits
when more plants or more trees are being
planted or whatever and let's just say
and that negative externality that's
coming from obvious things you know
these bags are going to be littered
they're going to be on the side of the
highway the city has to clean them up
they can there's environmental risks due
to them animals might eat them and choke
on them and turtles might drown and you
know whatever else because they're
choking on plastic bags or whatever else
and so they hire some experts and this
is not an easy thing to do but it's
determined that the negative externality
of these plastic bags is two cents two
cents per bag or another way to think of
it the cost to society and the
environment above and beyond the
marginal cost to the producers is two
cents per bag
now given that if we assume this
statement right over here and it's not
an easy thing to to come up with this
number but if we assume that this number
is true what then is the optimal amount
of bags to purchase and what are we
actually doing if we or what is the
optimum bags to produce and what are we
doing when we do produce this much and
to think about that let's create a new
curve this is a supplier's marginal cost
let's create another curve that is the
supplier plus society's marginal cost so
that first bag supplier opportunity cost
is about a penny but for society it's
costing another two cents so supplier
plus society is costing almost three
cents and so we can plot out another
curve we can plot out another curve
which we can view as the supplier
supplier
plus society
marginal cost so now we can think things
think of things in terms of total
benefit that's or total net benefit i
guess that's happening that very first
bag the supermarket that buys it is
getting still getting that over five
cents of benefit but now if we think
about the net benefit to society it's
not this whole height all the way down
to a penny it's only this part right
over here it's only the difference
between five and three is the marginal
is the marginal net benefit if you take
the marginal benefit and you subtract
out the total marginal cost including
the externalities and so the next bag
the total cost gets a little higher the
marginal benefit gets a little bit lower
and you keep it makes sense for society
you will keep getting benefit from this
if we think of the entire ecosystem
we'll keep getting benefit until we hit
this other equilibrium point over here
and once we get past that equilibrium
point now and we think holistically when
we think of the you know the environment
and and the government and all of that
now all of a sudden the marginal cost of
each incremental unit is higher than the
marginal benefit so if we were to
produce beyond that now we're incurring
costs
now we're essentially eating out all of
the benefit that we would have gotten if
we were to produce all the way to our
old equilibrium point over here we more
in the way look just eyeballing it this
area is more the purple area is more
than the yellow area we're now getting a
negative total benefit to society or you
could say a negative total surplus and
we haven't visualized it this way in the
past it's unusual for us to see a dead
weight a dead weight loss on this side
of the equilibrium point but you could
also view it that way so this right over
here is negative
negative surplus
negative surplus and so what you really
want holistically if you are the you
know the benevolent emperor emperor of
the society and you really want to
factor in all of the costs and benefits
of the plastic bags the ideal thing if
you want to optimize the benefit in
society you would want the equilibrium
price to be around here that looks like
about 350 and the equilibrium quantity
and the equilibrium quantity to be i
don't know this looks about 1.8 million
and you would not want all of this
excess quantity that is taking away that
is less efficient for society